The Persians were busy with other things
as well as thinking about returning to
Greece because the great king was not
willing and understandably in a way
to accept his defeat by these few puny
Greeks because of the consequences that
would have for the reputation of Persia.
And just as a matter of personal honor
these kings would not have been glad to
accept such an outcome.
I won't drag you through the details
of the invasion by the Persians and for
eighty. After all of making you read
Herodotus and the whole problem about it.
But let me simply talk a bit about the
conclusion to the great invasions of the
great Persian Wars as we call them and
also to say something about what their
meaning was the meaning of the defeat
of the Persians and 479 was broader than
the meaning of their
defeat at Marathon in 490.
For one thing it involved
the entire Greek nation.
Of course it wasn't the nation.
But you know I'm using the word loosely
of course it didn't involve the whole of
that nation no matter how loosely I use
it because if you imagine that there are
over a thousand plays there were only
thirty one who signed up to resist the
Persian invasion and for eighty however
they included the most important and
strongest and largest of the Greek poles.
So it's not too much of a stretch to speak
a bit speak of it as a Greek victory.
And again the same issue that had been
present at Marathon the question of
whether the Greeks would continue to
live their lives free in their place
developing their own style their unique
style of life or become another province
of the realm of the Persian
Empire just like so many others.
And we can see that in one wonderful
contemporary reference to the meaning of
the war it's in Aeschylus his first oldest
surviving play Persians in which the
central event is the great sea battle
at Salomon house in which the Greeks
defeat the Persian fleet which guarantees
that the Persians will not win a great
victory even though two more decisive
battles in the following year 479 are
necessary to drive the Persians away.
But here's what Aeschylus has
described in his play Persians.
He he's a he's having the story told by
and by I guess it's actually I'm trying
to remember it may well have been a
Persian who was telling this story but in
any case probably not it
was one of the Greeks.
Anyway here's what he says a mighty shout
greeted our ears on you sons of hell
us free your homeland free your children
your wives the homes of your father's
gods and the tombs of your ancestors.
In other words does this play was put
on something like oh about I think it's
about seven years after the Battle
of Salem is so it's it's almost a
contemporary event and you can see that
from the first the Greeks view this war
as being about freedom as opposed to
many other possible considerations.
And in the spring and the following
year in 479 there were two great battles
that decided the outcome of the war.
Finally on the land the battle of Plata
in southern B OCA in which a great Greek
army which included the major cities
including especially Sparta and Athens
took on a powerful Persian land
army and defeated them on land.
Herodotus says on the very same day it
would be a wonderful coincidence if it
were true but it may be
true a fundamentally a sea
battle was fought off the
coast of Asia Minor at my Cally where
again the Greek fleet once more destroyed
the Persian fleet and at that point the
Persians had no choice but simply to
flee and to try to escape the the Greeks
who were pursuing them and doing their
best to kill as many of them as they could
now.
After my colleague a very important
event took place that cast a long shadow
about the future of what was going
to happen in that part of the world.
There was a conference held on the
island of Samos perhaps one of the most
important of the Ionian Islands off the
coast which brought to the to the to the
Greek Council that had
been conducting the war.
It brought the island states
of chaos Lesbos and Samos.
These are the three largest most
important islands that are located off the
coast of Asia Minor.
All of them had taken advantage of the
presence of the Greek forces in that
region to rebel against the Persians.
And now they wanted to be admitted to
the league that the Greeks had formed in
for any one to resist the Persian invasion
the Greeks referred to themselves to
that league simply as the hellions the
Greeks and it's convenient to think about
it as the Greek league meant to
fight the Persians in that war.
Now this might seem like a simple thing
to do why not accept these three Greek
states all of them potentially powerful
and important who want to join the Greek
league.
One thing I think we need to understand
at once that we won't comprehend the
situation at all.
We know that the Persian Wars are over.
We know that the Persians just ran
away and weren't going to come back and
challenge this Greek victory
for the longest time.
But the Greeks didn't know it.
The Persian Empire was still intact it
was still an extraordinarily extensive
rich and powerful empire.
There was no reason why the Greeks should
not believe that the Persians would be
coming again.
And if we don't grasp that then all
of what they do now makes no sense.
Well chaos Samos and lemon and Lesbos
wanted to be sure that they would be
protected by this Greek league.
If and when the Persians came back and
tried to put them back into the Persian
Empire and so there was a conference
but there was not a unity of intention.
When the Greeks have to discuss shall
we take these people into our league
basically the Spartans said no.
And the reasons for that
I'm not so very strange.
The Spartans certainly could conclude
with security that there wasn't very much
danger that in the foreseeable future
the Persians would come marching into
Greece again and and present a threat
to the Peloponnese and to the Spartan
predominance in that area.
And we all know by now that the Spartans
were most reluctant to be far from home
anyway didn't like to have to cross the
sea to get to a battlefield and didn't
want their army out there
on any permanent basis.
Everything in their tradition said
bring the army home put an end to this
activity and they didn't want
to take on the responsibility of
bringing these islanders into their
league so that they would have to go and
fight for their freedom on the other hand
the Athenians took the opposite view.
They were very much in favor of
bringing these states into this thing.
Is this thing working. Is this
normal. Can you hear me back there.
Nothing's happening up here.
You want to forward this.
I can't tell. No it's not
working. A little bit all right.
Anyway I'll just continue to talk.
While technology takes place.
Mm hmm.
Anyway the Athenians thought differently
and that's not surprising either
because their situation was quite
different from that of the Spartans.
They were. On the sea. They
were accustomed to be at sea.
Moreover as we've seen and said several
times they had very important supply
line like.
Lines of communication and transportation
in order to feed themselves they
needed to go out there and have freedom
of the seas and that meant that they had
to see to it that the Persians were
indeed driven from the Aegean Sea and the
hellish spot.
And yet
the straits in general and
the access to the Black Sea.
So for those reasons alone the Athenians
would have had to take seriously this
request by the islanders.
But it's also true that at least some
of the islanders Samos particularly were
Ionian.
As you remember kinsman of the Athenians
the Athenians were recognized as the
leader of the Ionian people.
So there was that that
sentimental attachment as well.
But most strikingly I think we have to
understand that the Athenians understood
the Persians have to be kept away from
the Aegean Sea and the Athenians also
wanted very much because ever since
the rebellion of 499 the Athenians had
wanted to liberate.
The Greeks of Asia Minor
from the Persian rule.
You've got.
Thanks very much so.
And the Athenians won the argument.
It was agreed to take these three island
states into the Greek league and that
meant that the Greeks would be committed
to protect them should the Persians
attack them again and in accordance with
these decisions the commander of the
Spartan fleet out there kingly O ticket
has sailed home and took his Spartans.
And I would imagine this helping
nations with him on the other hand the
commander of the Athenian fleet sent
sippers state and carried on the war
against the Persians in the area. Let
me just give you a small clue since us.
We'll have a son.
Sorry.
He has a son in the here for 79 whose
name is parrot Cleaves and we will be
hearing of course a lot about him later
on since it is the Persians have fled
but there are a few places in Europe
that along the road the route of their
escape where the Persians left still
had control of a town or a city here and
there.
And one of the most important was the
town of systems located on the European
side of the the Dardanelles and so
sand Cyprus besieged the city with the
Athenian and the rest the Navy and the
rest of the Greek ships that were still
there.
And after a while took the city by siege
and cleared the Persians out of their
the result of the war was of course first
of all the vindication a validation of
Greek freedom.
Greeks would indeed continue to be able
to live the lives that they had been
accustomed to but another
thing had happened which was
going to make an enormous
impact on Greek life.
You perhaps will remember that before
the Persian invasion but not long before.
I believe it's in the year for 82 to the
silver mines in the south of Attica had
yielded an unusual strike a vein of
silver had been discovered that was much
more than normal.
And so much so that something had to
be decided by the Athenian assembly
what shall we do with the silver.
And this is a wonderful insight into the
way Greeks thought about their place at
the first thought.
The one that was most popular to begin
with was well let's take the silver and
divide it up equally among the Athenians
that in some sense the the polls was a
kind of a joint stock company and when
there was a nice dividend you just doled
out to the investors.
So Mr. Cleese thought otherwise mystically
as was it's evident constantly aware
of the threat from Persia and of the
importance of getting ready to fight the
Persians.
Then he understood I think before most
other Greeks that the Navy was going to
be really critical in this operation.
And so he made the suggestion that the
silver strike be used to build a whole
fleet of new ships for the Athenians and
they end up with two hundred try rings
which is to the tri RIM is the
battleship of the ancient Greeks.
So that.
That is the core of the fleet which is
the one that defeats the Persians at
salaries and defeats them again at my
Kelly the Spartans were given command of
the war against Persia
both on land and sea.
But the Spartans didn't have any great
skill or experience in naval matters.
And the Athenians had more than they
and it was the Athenian portion of the
fleet which was the largest and the
most effective in fighting those naval
battles and of course the battle of
Solomon was fought in Athenian waters.
And so Mr. Cleaves with his clever
devices had come up with a way of winning
victory.
First of all compelling the Greeks to
fight its elements and then winning the
victory itself.
Now the point of all this is one of the
changes that has come upon the Greek
world as a result of this Persian invasion
is that there is something new in the
Greek world a big Athenian Navy
and it has proven itself already
to be an extraordinarily capable Navy.
And that is a new power factor.
And the whole idea of naval power being
very decisive in Greek affairs is a
relatively new idea.
That's not to say that there weren't
states that had navies before and naval
battles and in some cases that
these were very important.
But we're really at another level.
After the Athenians have built this
fleet and had the success that they have
made they had.
And another consequence of the
war was of course the tremendous
boom that came in Greek
self-confidence it really.
I can't emphasize enough
what an incredible upset
this was no one would have
imagined that if the great king was got
really serious and sent over an army of
well you know one hundred thousand two
hundred thousand nobody knows exactly how
many Herodotus his numbers are.
It is widely agreed exaggerated
but there's a very big
army and a very big Navy
certainly outnumbers the
Greeks in both cases.
And if anybody would have thought that
was going to be an easy victory for the
Persians to defeat that
meant an enormous amount.
And the Greeks came away feeling that
their general prejudice of their own
superiority over everybody else had been
justified by their performance in the
Persian Wars the Athenians no less.
Of course because of the very
central role that they had played.
So all of these are new things that are
in the hearts and minds of the Greeks
and by no means trivial.
There was a sense that the Greeks had
done something remarkably glorious not to
be forgotten which made them proud and
made them I think also rather ambitious
to continue in that course.
And finally one other point I would want
to make in that is this is the first
great pan hellenic activity really.
There had been some sense in which the
Greeks were increasingly aware that there
was something called
Helen's Greek people's.
Different from people
who were not hellions.
And this took probably took shape most
fully when they competed in the major
athletic contests at major religious
festivals in which they were fundamentally
Greek even though.
Well they were entirely Greek really.
So that would have fostered
this sense of handhelds.
But nothing could have given
it a tremendous boost that
it got like this victory
of these 31 states that had
banded together to defeat
the Persians in that war.
So Pan Helen ism is now on the horizon.
I don't mean to say that
the Greeks are shaped now.
Into a single people have retreated from
their localism and their love for the
Poles.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
But alongside of their love of autonomy
and love of their place there was the
idea that pan Helen ism was a good thing.
It had a kind of a nice ring to it.
It's the sort of thing that
I feel some familiarity with.
Not that I was around right
after the first world war but
reading about it you realized that
there was some sense after that war.
That the victorious peoples had something
in common and that in any case they
could work together to
achieve international peace
and in a way that hadn't been
thought of much before.
But even more strongly I think the idea
after the Second World War when this
idea took even stronger route to the
point where people have this crazy
religious feeling or at least some of
them do about the desire to avoid having
parochial national interests determine
what you're going to do in international
relations.
Everything has to be done
somehow as though there were
a rule a world government
that really existed and really managed
things and although everybody knows
that's not true it's thought to
be bad form to face that fact.
Well something like that kind.
Not as bad as that but something like
that kind of unreality was in the minds of
Greeks because you will be hearing over
the next century various thinkers and
speakers who want to make the case that
a thing is good if it's somehow pan
hellenic. That's a fine thing.
So it's an idea that's there.
Not that any state any more than our
nations have given up any sovereignty or
any independence or any autonomy.
It's an idea and that's all that it is.
Another consequence of the war was a
division in the Greek within the Greek
world that was in part based upon the
fact that Athens said Come on in that war
to become a great power.
And by anybody's reckoning had played
one of the leading roles in the victory.
Now the Spartans had to the Spartans were
the official leaders and their Regent
had been the commander at the great land
battle at Pelletier and their general
was in charge of the Navy.
But Athens had become so important so
big so successful that there was now a
question.
I mean it was part of really the leader
of the Greeks. What was the future.
Was the future going to be one in which
the Spartans would maintain the unique
leadership of the Greeks or would
the Athenians challenge them.
It soon became clear that the Athenians
would indeed challenge them and so a
major theme may be the major theme in
international relations for the next 50
years will be the conflict
between Athens and Sparta.
And a lot of it I think could be
described really as a Cold War.
Because there is no fighting between the
two states between for 79 and about 460
or even a little bit late.
Actually I don't come into conflict
themselves until four fifty seven again.
And when that war stops there is a period
once again of peace and then we come
to the great Peloponnesian War which
dominates the last third of the century.
That's all in the future.
But what's clear now is that there's
got to be some new arrangement some new
alignment to face up to the
change in the power structure.
There was only one great
power before the war.
There clearly are two after the war.
Well the Greeks also had to decide
certain questions that had been created by
the war.
One of them who's to be the leader if
there is to be a leader of the Greeks.
But beyond that there was some Greek
states that had gone over to the Persians
in the course of the war and the
Greeks refer to these people as me or.
What should be done with the me dies.
I'm sure there were proposals from one
extreme that would have said just wipe
those cities out to the other extreme
which would have said well let bygones be
bygones.
But there were opinions all
along the middle of the way.
And so that remained an issue
that had to be settled somehow.
And then behind it all was the question
What shall we look for in the future.
Was Persia going to be a threat once
again which would imply one whole set of
policies or can we consider the threat
from Persia finished so that we can go
back to our normal way without
adjusting to that policy.
And in for the reasons I've already
indicated the Spartans and the the nations
who have a lot more likely to take
the view that the threat was over the
Athenians the islanders and the Ionian
and the I should say the Asiatic Greeks
would take the view that no there is a
very imminent danger from the Persians.
The war isn't over.
We need to continue to fight it.
Now let me then try to
describe the way in which a new
way of dealing with the Persians would
come onto the scene and for that I need
to take you back to for any one year
when Xerxes started his march from the
Persian empire against the Greeks.
The Greeks knew this was
happening and they met.
You will remember at Corinth in 481 when
those 31 cities came together and swore
that they would fight together
to defeat the Persians.
They appointed Sparta.
Officially as the head Jarmon the leader
of that league which meant that the
Spartans would be in command on land and
sea and once the battles commenced that
they would be in charge.
But of course the decisions as to what
to do what where to go to fight went to
fight and so on were made by the Council
of Greeks who were participating in the
Spartans did not attempt
to impose their wishes.
At that point so that the league really
functions like a league of equals but of
course the states are
not equal in their power.
So that is much more
influenced by the Spartans.
But there's also a lot of influence by
the Athenians because of the size of
their fleet.
That's the way things were working
in the Greek league against Persia.
Even though the Spartans are the hedge
German Do not confuse this league with
the Peloponnesian league.
It is something quite different.
I've already described the league to you
and so you know that the relationships
are different and the
membership is different.
The Greek league has states that are
not in the Peloponnese and have not
previously been allied to Sparta.
It also includes Spartans traditional
Peloponnesian allies they swear this
common oath the Greeks
are to fight for the common freedom to
free the Greeks and the islands and Asia
Minor and it is to be a perpetual League
as we know because as late as four
sixty one.
I guess the when there was a conflict
between Athens and Sparta the Athenians in
fact withdraw from their alliance
with the Greeks under Spartan rules.
So that tells us that until then they
fell for themselves still to be part of
that Greek league they agreed and for
anyone to put aside the quarrels that they
may have had at the time and to have
the same friends and enemies the famous
clause that means a common foreign policy.
But it doesn't mean again it just because
the Spartans ahead us doesn't mean the
Spartans will determine that policy the
policy will be determined by the league
in its own meetings it is to
be a typical Greek alliance.
The Greek word for that is simple.
Here it means an offensive
and defensive alliance.
I will fight along your side
not only if you are attacked.
But if you go to war against
somebody else at your own discretion.
I still am bound to be your ally.
That's what I say mafia is so far
as we know that's the only kind of
international alliance
that the Greeks knew.
Up to that time offensive and defensive
nothing is said about money.
There is no provision for
providing funds for the league.
I think that implies very clearly each
state would pay for its own forces when
they were engaged in the common cause.
There was no provision
for regular meetings.
Meetings would be held when they
were thought to be necessary.
And of course everything would have
to be done by the common consent.
I don't mean that there was a need for
unanimity but there certainly would have
to be a general agreement of things.
For the game to go forward.
This is a new thing.
It's an innovation and of course it fits
in nicely with what I said a moment ago
about the concept of Pan
Helen ism coming forward.
This is the first pan hellenic
expedition I suppose since the Trojan War
now.
Sparta.
As as you've seen when the decision had
to be made as to whether they should
commit themselves to defending the islands
with a kind of a permanent force out
there to do that the Spartans withdrew.
Nothing is formal there's no change in
the arrangements but they just decided to
go home.
And now we see that the Athenians
will be pursuing a different policy.
The one that was ultimately adopted by
most of the Greeks but which allowed the
Athenians to come forward and make the
kinds of claims for their influence that
they would one of the first
things the Athenians wanted to do.
I should remind you that the Persians
had marched into Attica and done fearful
damage to the police of Athens the palace
of Athens and had done great harm to
the city of Athens had gone up to the
Acropolis destroyed the temples that
existed there a terrible sacrilege from
the point of view of the Athenians and
they wanted to do what they could to
see this would never happen again.
And so they undertook to
build the walls around the.
I hope it's going to come to
me in a minute the Acropolis
stronger than they had
been.
And also to make the city walls
stronger than they had been.
Now it's interesting it's an interesting
sign of the way some of the other Greek
states felt that when the Athenians set
about building their walls there were
complaints from some of the Greek allies
to the Spartans that the Athenians were
doing this and saying this was a bad idea.
My guess is that the complainants would
have included such cities as thieves
Majora probably currents thieves and
mega of being both neighbors a budding on
Attica and old enemies of the Athenians
and the Corinthians being just next door
so to speak.
Not quite on their border but also a
state that was undoubted will undoubtedly
challenge by the emergence of Athens
as a great naval power and a great
commercial power.
Currents had happened that had one of
the biggest navies and cards for the
longest time had been a
great commercial power.
The archeological evidence is that it was
being challenged in the latter respect
by the Athenians as early
as in the 6th century.
So these are the kind of states that
would have been complaining and thinking
that if the Athenians had a walled city
that they could defend that would make
them more
confident and possibly more aggressive
and more trouble for their neighbors
and in the war the Athenians should had
shown an astonishing daring especially
at sea which obviously was making some
of their old enemies and neighbors
nervous Well the Spartans
heard about it and they heeded
their friend's complaints enough.
So that's the mistake please.
Who was I need to point out to you though
I'm sure you know it emerged from the
war as the great hero.
He had done so many wonderful things.
He was responsible for the Athenian Navy.
He was responsible for the
decision to fight at Salomon.
He was responsible people believe
for the victory it's Alan as
we hear.
Butcher tells wonderful stories about in
the Olympic Games right after the war.
People will watching the games
when the mystically is arrive.
They stop watching the games
and they watch domestically.
Because so great was the admiration
and wonder that he created.
I always I try to figure out some analogy
now but I can't if you imagine if you
could wrap up Roosevelt Churchill and
Stalin and make him one person after a
second world war. You might have
something like what mystically is dead.
So so mystically goes to Sparta.
And he of course is the main champion
in Athens of Athens rebuilding its walls
as fast as possible and Athens taking
the most forward position possible in the
Navy at sea and in international
relations in general.
And he does this little trick
that the facilities described.
He says he will go to to Sparta but
the Spartans either send some people to
Athens too.
And then he tells the Athenians to hold
those Spartans there until he gets home.
The next thing he says is let me know
when the walls have been built high enough
to defend so he goes to talk to the
Spartans as fights as we hear you guys are
building walls around there.
You know I know it's your own business
but we don't think that's a good idea
because if the Persians come again they
could use your walled city as a base
against us if you can follow
that kind of reasoning.
Your sharper than I am.
But
anyway that's the story
they told isn't it.
Where did you hear that nonsense. We're
building walls up. A lot of baloney.
Forget about it. I'm sorry I
haven't told the story quite right.
He says Look don't take my word for it.
You send an embassy to Athens and take
a look. That's when he told his friends.
Keep those guys there until I get home.
So one day the message I'm a messenger
from Athens comes to the mystic leaves
and tells him OK.
The walls can now be defended whereupon
mystically says to the Spartans you know
those walls you were complaining about.
You were right.
We do have them and they're now big enough
that we can defend ourselves against
them.
And what are you going to do about and
then he delivers a speech which is a kind
of a declaration not so much of
independence as of equivalence
to the Spartans.
His message was we don't take orders
from you keep your advice to yourselves.
We'll take care of ourselves.
You take care of yourselves.
You are not our superiors.
We are your equals was the
essence of what he said.
Thereafter Mr. it was not so
popular in Sparta as it used to be.
Indeed for the rest of his life the
Spartans will be trying to do him harm and
remove him from the scene.
But he certainly achieves what he wants.
The Athenians are a walled city and
they have declared that whatever their
formal technical relationship with Sparta
might be under the Hellenic League.
The fact is they are independent players
and they're going to do things as they
see fit.
Consider this says the Spartans accepted
this but secretly they were embittered.
I think that's the first clue we have to
what will become a continuing situation
in Sparta for the rest of the time we pay
attention to them that there will be a
factional division among Spartans.
At least this much is true.
I'm sure it's much more complicated than
we know but in the simplest way there
was some Spartans who were content to
withdraw back to the Peloponnese is to
have nothing to do with the world outside
the Peloponnese is much less with the
world of the Aegean Sea and beyond and
try to return to their traditional ways.
A peace faction if you will a conservative
faction perhaps but that there is
also starting now as a result
of the victory in the war.
A faction of Spartans that would like to
exert Spartan power and influence more
broadly.
At least to incur include the rest of
the Greek states of the mainland but also
a number of them surely felt that
they wanted to exert power everywhere
including overseas as well.
But that that faction that second faction
doesn't win the argument they have to
be secretly embittered
because the official policy
of Sparta is to accept this.
The Athenian situation and we'll see in
a moment that events move them in the
same direction.
The commander of the Spartan forces at
play here who emerges as the leading
figure immediately after the war he is
POW seniors who was there a region but
effectively one of the two kings of.
Sparta.
He goes out to the Aegean Sea.
Member of the previous king in commander
had retired but now pass any it takes a
fleet and he goes out there and he
proceeds to make the Greeks first he
perceives to be very effective
against the Persians.
He does some fighting particularly in
the hellish spot and the Straits in
general Byzantium is a
very important city there.
What later becomes Constantinople and
then Istanbul and the and the little town
across the way so they
control the Straits.
He defeats the Persians and so on but in
the process he makes enemies among the
Greeks part of the reason is because
he treats the Greeks as inferiors as if
they were underlings of the Spartans.
In general it appears to have been a
common Spartan problem that when they went
out of Sparta and had commanding
positions over other Greeks they regularly
treated them in that way different degrees
of course poor seniors must have been
particularly annoying.
But there were main complaints about how
they were treated by his Greek allies.
In addition he became very much caught
up in the great wealth and luxury that
the Persians demonstrated.
Greeks were most Greeks were at least
theoretically very appalled at the morals
or the lack of morals of the Persians
from their perspective but their Persians
were first of all very
rich and Greeks were not.
And they use their wealth for various
purposes all of which were seen to be on
Greek and unattractive
parsimonious fell for it.
And he began behaving as though he were
a Persian sat track at the very least.
All of these things as I say irritated
their fellow Greeks who began to bring
charges against him.
He was charged in Sparta with first
of all tyranny and then second of all
treason.
He was alleged to have been cut out to
have cut some kind of a deal with the
Persian ruler and his set
traps against the common cause.
The this was effective enough to
have him recall and put on trial.
He was acquitted on the other hand.
He was not sent out again
to be the commander.
He was put on the side.
Later on further charges would be brought
against him and he would indeed be put
to death.
OK.
But the main point is that the Spartans
have withdrawn their commander pretty
much in disgrace with
the rest of the Greeks.
They send out a replacement.
A man called Dorcas.
The allies don't accept him and they
say no we're not taking any Spartan
commanders these days
and send him back home.
That is an extremely important step.
The allies.
And that means now the people in the
Aegean Sea and on its borders the people
who are in what will be first the
Athenian sphere of influence and then the
Athenian Empire. These are the states
that they that don't want Spartan rule.
And I think the main reason is well
there's a couple of reasons one is a the
behavior of past enemies has discredited
the Spartans but the other I think is
this look how much evidence do you need
that the Spartans really don't like this
kind of thing.
You remember they had voted against
taking those three islands into the league
even back there in 479.
So.
And the other thing is that here are the
Athenians the guys who really won the
war at sea which is the one
you're concerned about and
who are apparently ready
and waiting to continue to do that.
And it was I think that choice that was
in the minds of the allies when they
sent Dorcas home and said please no more.
And the Spartans did not send
a replacement for Dorcas.
They in other words accepted that they
would not participate in the future
campaigns against Persia which would be
obviously aggressive campaigns in Asia
since the Persians had been driven out
of Europe and out of the Aegean Sea.
Facility says this about
the Spartan decision.
They also wanted to be rid of the Persian
War and believed that the Athenians
were competent to lead and were at
the present time well-disposed to the
Spartans. Why not. They said we
don't want to fight this war.
We don't really care about those things
and everything will be OK because the
Athenians can do it and
they're all friends but surely
that was not what all the
Spartans saw.
That was the opinion of the faction
that won the argument which was the
conservative faction the one
that was the peace party.
And let's stay in the Peloponnese party
was still the predominant force and I
suspect their position had
been strengthened by the
disgrace brought upon Sparta
by the behavior of seniors and no
doubt by the rejection of the Spartan
replacement by the other Greeks.
Why should we force ourselves.
We are making ourselves unpopular.
It used to be the Greeks came to us and
begged us to fight and protect them when
they were in trouble.
And now they're rejecting our leadership.
That's because we shouldn't be out there.
This is not our kind of a campaign.
This is. Well what can go on and
imagine the arguments that we use
did this mean that there would be no
continuing campaign against Persia.
Certainly not.
That is not what the allies meant.
They turned to Athens and asked the
Athenians to take the lead in the war that
was going to cost
Herodotus has a line in which he says
the Athenians offered the hubris of power
seniors as a pretext for taking over the
leadership of the Greeks out there that
suggests that the Athenians were planning
to do just that that they very much
wanted to and that they were engaged
in maneuvers to bring it about.
That it was their idea that
they took the initiative.
But I think that's not right. I let me
back up a step. It's only partly right.
What is certainly clear
is that the Athenians were
ready and willing to do what
they were asked but the idea that they
either use their power and influence or
their wiles to bring the allies to take
that decision when they would not have
otherwise done so.
I think that is wrong.
I'm gonna start doing something
that you may get tired of after a.
I want to use an analogy that I
find very illuminating anyway.
The analogy of the formation of NATO
after the Second World War and the
formation of the deeply in League which
is ultimately turned into the Athenian
Empire after the Persian Wars
in the case of the dealing league I think
the Norwegian or Swedish scholar has
described the process whereby NATO was
invented as the establishment of head
Germany by invitation.
That is if you look at the situation
nineteen forty five six seven eight nine
the European states that ultimately
became part of NATO desperately wanted the
Americans to join with them not to
repeat what they had done after the first
world war which was to retreat back into
North America to have no connections of
a political military kind with Europe
which terrified the European states that
were sort of knocked down so hard by
the Second World War and who were afraid
that the Soviet Union was going to take
them over and they desperately wanted
the Americans to take the lead.
Now the Americans were glad to do it.
I don't mean all the Americans.
As always there were factions and the
differences of opinions and the the
American president and his government had
to fight hard to convince Americans to
do it.
But by and large they did and those who
won the argument were of the opinion
that American interests first of all
in reaching restoring Europe to its
previous condition and
secondly to resisting communist
takeover Soviet takeover
of Europe meant that it was in America's
interests to see that such a situation
develop both sides I would argue were
equally glad to see what happened because
it was in the interest of both sides.
So I think it was in for seven to eight
seven when the formation of the Dalian
League took place.
Obviously the states that were bordering
on the Persian Empire and in the seas
next to Asia Minor were absolutely
at risk if the Persians came back.
Supposing the Athenians said they weren't
interested and had gone home just as
the Persians said there was no Greek
force except for the poor Asiatic Greeks
themselves to resist a Persian return
and they couldn't possibly resist that.
So for them it was a life and death
matter at least it was a matter of freedom
versus slavery that they should
persuade the Athenians to take the lead.
But for the Athenians who won the argument
it was obvious they felt our needs
for instance access to the Black Sea.
However our feelings.
Friendship for the Greeks of Asia Minor
and our fear fear of what the Persians
might do if they got rolling.
All point to the same outcome.
And so I think both sides were equally
glad to undertake this new path.
I think we will be deeply mistaken if
we imagine that anybody imposed his will
on anybody else in this matter
and in fact the Athenians according
to Plutarch story needed persuasion.
Plutarch tells the tale of Aristophanes
who was in command of the Athenian fleet
there off Asia Minor at the time when
the same eons particularly took the lead
and came to the Athenians
into Aristophanes and said
Won't you please be our
leaders.
Aristotle said before we do that you show
us that you are really committed to us
and that you will not simply use us.
I mean I'm putting in stuff
that's not a complete task.
Now don't use us as a kind of a way of
convincing the Spartans to stay and then
leave us in the lurch.
So you ladies the commander of the samy
and Navy turned took his ship sailed it
against the flagship of poor seniors.
This is at the time and past seniors
is still around and rams that ship.
Well that ought to take care of any
possibility of playing footsie with the
Spartans.
At which point the Athenians accept the
leadership and then move forward with
the plan for doing so in
the winter of 478 seven.
There was a meeting of the Greeks who are
interested at the island of deep loss.
The losses right smack in the middle of
the Aegean Sea and as I've told you it
is the
birthplace of Apollo and Artemus and
Apollo of course is got a special fondness
for the irony.
And so it's the natural place for this
to happen and they come up with what
amount is essentially a
constitutional convention.
They come up with a constitution that
will describe how the league is to work.
The aims of the league are.
That the members of the league will fight
against the Persians first of all to
avenge what the Persians did to the
Greeks and secondly to collect booty from
the Persians to pay for the
damage that the Persians did.
So that is a part of the
story I think of course.
Implicit.
It didn't have to be said that the
primary motive must be to maintain or
establish I would guess and maintain
the freedom of the Greeks from Persian
rule.
The city doesn't mention that and some
scholars have been misled into thinking
that somehow that wasn't
part of the story.
Well how could they do the rest
of it if they didn't do that.
These states were obviously in danger
of being taken by the Persians so their
freedom had to be the maintenance of their
freedom had to be step number one and
surely that was clear in their minds.
They agreed as it was typical in the
Greek alliances to have the same friends
and enemies common foreign
policy and to carry this forward.
They all swore oaths that's their form
of signing treaties they don't sign
treaties they swear oaths
then they dropped.
Iron chunks of iron into the sea as
a symbol that this treaty was to be
perpetual.
That is to say it would last until the
iron came up and floated on the surface.
They knew that wasn't going to happen.
So they are us a standard kind of an
alliance with a perpetual I need to make
the point that most Greek alliances that
we hear of in this period are not the
the
unions and the Spartans in four forty
five make a thirty years piece in four
twenty one they make fifty years peace
on another occasion they make a five year
peace that's that's the way they do
things normally this is different.
This is like.
The Greek Lee.
This is a perpetual alliance.
The membership of the league
as best we can figure it out.
This is not 100 percent
accurate but it's not bad.
It includes a first of all informally
at this point it divides the league up
into zones one is the islands of the GNC
and we have knowledge of 20 towns that
are members from the islands Ionia that
is on the coast of Asia Minor itself 36
towns along the Hellas Pantene route into
the Black Sea 35 carrier which is the
southern coast of Asia Minor has 24 3s
which is the northern shore of the Aegean
Sea in Greek territory is thirty is thirty
three comes to a total of one hundred
and forty eight.
You imagine you're talking about one
hundred and fifty towns you've got the
general idea right.
So that's quite an amazing thing.
Peloponnesian league certainly didn't
have anything like that in terms of
numbers of states.
But don't be too carried away because
lots of these places are just tiny little
spots especially when you're
talking about islands.
Some of the islands states in the Aegean
and they apparently were just about all
members are very small indeed.
Still it includes some very important
states like those big islands I mentioned
already Samos chaos and Lesbos and others
that were not quite as big and some
states on the Asian side that were
old and big and important cities.
My leaders being one example of it.
So
there it is.
Notice what I have not
including no Taliban nations.
This is not in any shape manner or form
connected with the Peloponnesian Lee and
I like. I think I'm going to play
my analogy game in a moment too.
But what I want to say is you need to be
easiest I think for you to grasp what's
going on.
If you think of three
separate organizations first
there's the Greek league
against Persia that was formed in for
eighty one which includes Peloponnesian
states and non Peloponnesian states.
Then keep in mind the oldest of these.
I should have mentioned first
the Peloponnesian League
which is older than the
Greek League which includes four.
For our purposes essentially
only Peloponnesian states.
There are a couple of exceptions but
none are are across the sea in any way.
And then there's this newly which
we should call the Dalian league.
Although the Greeks referred to it as
the Greeks just as they had the earlier
lead.
But this that it's easier to think of
it as the deal in league to separate it
from that league.
OK here's the analogy that I suggest
that the Greek league against Persia we
might think of as being like the United
Nations organization because it includes
states from both sides
from all of these places.
And I think if we think
of the Peloponnesian Lee
as one of the subordinate
leagues and the dealing
league as the other.
In other words like NATO on the one
hand and the Warsaw Pact on the other.
That will be a helpful analogy because
first of all both of them are members of
the Greek league too.
And but as the United Nations
Organization charter permits regional
associations.
So NATO and the Warsaw Pact where
regional associations so too without there
being any formality about it.
It clearly didn't mean to abolish the
Peloponnesian league and therefore there
was no reason why they shouldn't be a
different regional alliance like that of
the dealing only that I think is the
structure of the international system in
Greece as we move past the Persian Wars
now let's say a little bit
more about that deal league.
There are more things you
need to know about it.
It is a germinal league.
Just like the Peloponnesian league
that is there is a designated leader.
Athens is the designated
regiment of the league and
there is also something that's something
quite different something new since
this is a naval league.
It costs money in a way that a military
league made of hotlines citizens
doesn't.
So it was clear there had to be some
league money a league Treasury for this
purpose.
They declared the collection of something
they called a force Ross P H O R O S
it just simply means in the
most neutral sense contribution.
As time passed this contribution was seen
to be something imposed upon unwilling
payers and in English.
We we use the word to
describe it as tribute.
But let's think now for the moment only
about the beginning of the league and
what was intended at first.
So there is this contribution
which becomes the league
Treasury the assessor was
an Athenian general Aristotle's
REIT is the just as he was known.
He told each state how much it
would be required to contribute.
This took the form in the beginning.
In some cases of ships and crews to
Rosen and in other states from the very
beginning.
Money.
Now I think we should imagine that the
earlier you are in the league the more
there are.
Allied ships and crews.
And as you get later and later until
finally you're into the Peloponnesian War
just about every state doesn't have a
fleet of its own doesn't supply cruise but
just pays money.
Again I urge you to think about the
beginning and not worry about the end just
now.
So the Athenian assesses that there is
also an Athenian citizen who will be
chosen for the job of treasurer of this
new league Hellenic Tommy us as the
Greek.
The Greek word and he will see to the
collection and the security of that money
and Athenian does that also.
Any military or naval campaigns conduct
conducted on behalf of the Dalian league
will have an Athenian general in charge.
Now you know looking at it backwards
you can say well this is Athenian
imperialism and the Athenians
are imposing their power on no.
The Allies would have been the first to
want to do this because what they were
afraid of.
Just because the Europeans were afraid
in the 40s was not that the ally that the
Athenians would lorded over them.
They were afraid that the Athenians would
run away and leave them to their fate.
They wanted to tie the Athenians
into this new organization.
Now this deal in league is unsurpassed
among the few international organizations
there are in the Greek world.
It was enormously efficient because
you had a leader who was designated and
interested and deeply involved.
You had.
An organ for making decisions.
I haven't mentioned it but there was
what they called the synod of the league
gets the Council of the league in which
there are representatives from every
state and it can make all the decisions
that have to be made in that one place.
Unlike these other places it has its
own money and its own forces which are
assigned to it by the Constitution.
All of these things make that a much more
effectively able to do what it has to
do
without any great difficulty in the
decision making process and to make that a
little clearer I need to
tell you another thing.
In the Synod the arrangement was one
state one vote so Athens was a one member
of that Synod Athens which had
the lion's share of the power.
Had only one vote.
So how could the Athenians have their way.
You may ask but the way it really worked
was because Athens had all of this
prestige and all of this power it meant
all of the very small powerless states
huddled under the wings of the Athenians
and could be counted on to deliver the
right sort of vote to do
what the Athenians told him.
Whereas supposing they had used something
like proportional representation given
the Athenians X number of votes a lot
of votes but they would have had to give
safe source and I don't mean face to
face all still but Samos chaos Lesbos all
these big towns and islands numerous votes
as well and they would certainly have
been more votes than the Athenians had.
They could have voted then the Athenians
if they got together under this one man
one one state one vote rule.
That's impossible.
We never never hear of any trouble
passing whatever the Athenians want in the
assembly.
There's just no check on their doing
what they want in a constitutional way
now.
So long as everybody's playing by the
original rules this doesn't really present
any serious problem. But as time passes
and there are differences of opinion.
And as for various reasons I will explain.
The Athenians begin to assert their
power and begin to change the situation.
It's at that point that the question of
autonomy will arise and the Athenians
will in fact interfere with the autonomy
of the other states and turn the league
ultimately into what the Greeks called
an ah Hey which we rightly translate as
an empire.
But once again I don't want you to think
about that when you're thinking about
the situation in 477 that's in the
future and that's not what people are
expecting or wanting.
There is a common interest and it's very
strong and 477 to deal with the threat
of the Persia.
And to get revenge and payment from
the Persians for what has happened the
problem only emerges or problems emerge
when the challenge from Persia recedes
and as we shall see that's of course
was the same problem that NATO suffered
from and suffers from today which is
to the degree that they don't feel
threatened by anything the states that
are allied to the United States don't
feel they have to do
what the Americans want.
And that's the way it was when
the situation developed in Greece.
OK so that's the original
situation of the dealing only.
And I want to turn next to the story of
how that turns into the Athenian Empire.
And the first thing I want to indicate
to you is that the success of the deal
only from the outset was extraordinary.
Well one little town that was still in
Persian hands in 477 was the town of E.ON
located at the mouth of the stream on
river up in Thrace the Athenian commander
took of league fleet to E.ON and drove
the Persians out soon thereafter.
By the way the dates that we
have for this are very insecure.
They are mostly derived from the story
that two cities tells us it's a very the
details are very few and he doesn't
give us very many good dates if any.
So there's a certain amount of estimation.
It doesn't really matter from your point
of view but I don't want I will give
you dates that are those that are commonly
accepted but you mustn't imagine that
they're firmly fixed.
Anyway some years not too many after the
establishment of the league the league
under the great Athenian commander who
will play a larger and larger role in
league affairs and then and also in
Athenian political affairs came on takes
this force against the island
of scare us in the Aegean.
Scare us was attacked because
it was not inhabited by Greeks.
It was inhabited by non Greek peoples
who made their living out of piracy.
Well clearly all the states of the
league had a lot to lose from allowing
pirates to roam freely in their
waters and so came on crushed.
The Syrians pirates and to make sure he
drove them from the island and he made
sure that the island would be secure
by putting an Athenian cleric.
Remember that cleric.
The Athenians put in a near Karl kiss.
This is the same kind of arrangement
Athenians of military age who permanently
settle in scare us but retain
their Athenian citizenship.
They are a garrison in effect to protect
the island of scare us from falling
into bad hands.
In the future it was widely believed and
justifiably that came on in that force
had liberated the Aegean Sea.
We never hear about piracy anymore.
Piracy was a problem that the states in
the Mediterranean in general suffered
from a lot and at different
times very very seriously.
One thing that this new league even and
when it's the daily league one becomes
18 an empire.
There is no piracy in the
region where that lead exists.
Then they turn to the city of Christos
which is at the southern end of the
island WBA ends you remember had under
the greatest military pressure actually
surrendered to the Persians given earth
and water and so technically they were
mi visors and there was
no mercy shown to them.
They were compelled they didn't wish to
do this but they were compelled to join
the deal only and to pay
a cash contribution not to
be allowed to provide their
own ships.
Thus almost from the very beginning
there is one instance of a state which
doesn't fit the general picture I've
been painting a state that is a subject
state and is compelled to be a member
but it's just this one case of a meat
izing state.
Then possibly in the year 470
another development we hear that the
island of Naxos seems to be an island full
of trouble.
Every time we hear of next us getting
into difficulties or some kind or another
but they decided that there wasn't
any great threat from Persia that the
Persians weren't coming back.
And so they said we're quitting the league
well I'm sure somebody said don't you
remember you swore this oath you
threw some higher lumps into the sea.
Do you see any iron floating around here
in the Aegean Sea. You're not quitting.
They rebelled the league sent the fleet.
They put down the next rebellion and
Nexus was now reduced from the category of
a free ally.
Making the kinds of contributions the
other allied state did to another subject
state which paid money didn't.
The walls were taken down
their fleet was taken away.
And that's the pattern that we shall
see states who don't carry out their
responsibilities states that
particularly try to rebuild will be
treated this way and their number will
increase as time passes.
Now so far by the way we do not hear of
anybody in the league objecting to these
decisions and these actions nor should
we expect that there would be the allies
still believed they needed this league
and they weren't about to let people get
a free ride such as Christmas
would whether they paid or not.
The Persians weren't going to attack
them so they ought to pay for states like
Naxos who decided well we
feel safe enough so we quit.
That wasn't gonna be permitted.
Well in a sense what you can really see
from this is that the league was working
as it was supposed to to be able to do
the job that it had to and then if the
dates are right in the next year 469 comes
a very important turning point in the
history of the league.
The Persians have a fleet
in the well I guess.
You can't really call it the Aegean it's
around the corner on the southern coast
of Asia Minor.
You remote on river flows out there and
they had a fleet and an army inland.
The league forces went there to that
year Ramadan under the command of came on
defeated and crushed the Persian fleet
at sea landed and defeated the Persian
army on the land.
And that was a terrible blow to
the Persian position in the eastern
Mediterranean.
The evidence is apparently that
the Persians had a pull back.
From that entire area and
it would not have been
at all unreasonable for people to think
well the Persian threat really is over.
This is beyond what happened in 479.
It's not just that we've
driven them out of Europe.
We've driven them away
from the Mediterranean Sea.
You could imagine that that's just the
end of the Persian threat that was not
the view taken by the Athenians
or I guess by most of the allies.
But we can imagine that there were some
of the allies who were restless in their
need to continue to make contributions
to the league when they didn't feel that
there was any purpose for
the league anymore here.
I gave a hint to this earlier.
I don't remember what the
general GRUNTS There was.
The second commander of NATO.
But he was anyway.
He was an earlier commander of NATO.
He's obviously a West Point man educated.
He knew all about facilities
in the Peloponnesian War.
And so he made the analogy between the
first time I'm aware that anybody did
between NATO and the Dalian league and
he was doing so as commander of NATO at a
period when he felt that the American
allies in Europe were more and more
reluctant to make the kinds
of contributions that he
thought they should make
and was being wailing his situation
which was every time the Russians looked
like they were going to behave then the
allies decided they didn't want to make
any contributions.
And then when the Russians look scary
everybody came running and said sure sure
we'll continue. And he suggested that's
the way it was in the deal and league to.
So keeping the back of your mind that
there are real questions out there in the
league as to whether it should persist
and we'll carry this story forward next
time.